-One of our writers, Karen,
she is 25 years old.
As a result, she has a much
different frame of reference
than I do,
so I thought I'd find out
how much Karen knows
about the past
in a segment called
"What Does Karen Know?"
♪♪
-Hi, Karen. How are you?
-I'm good. How are you?
-Good.
I miss seeing you in person,
but it's lovely to see
you virtually this way.
-It's so nice to see you too!
-How has been --
How has the pandemic been
for a 25-year-old?
-Um, I mean for me particularly
as someone who doesn't go out
much to begin with, you know,
just a little bit more sadness.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
Are you ready for another trip
down my memory lane
to see if it triggers
a memory in you?
-Yes, I'm excited.
I've done some studying.
-Okay, great.
You've studied the '80s
and the '90s and whatnot?
-Oh.
I think I went back too far.
Never mind, that's --
-[ Laughs ]
How dare you, Karen?
How dare you?
Alright. Here's our first item.
Does this mean anything to you,
Karen?
-Um, no.
It almost -- My initial thought
was like a pogo stick,
but that's definitely not true.
-Nah, not a pogo stick.
-Is it like a water gun
of some kind?
-It's not a water gun.
Karen, it's a Bop It.
Does that mean anything to you?
-Oh, yes, I do.
I have heard of Bop Its.
-What have you heard
about the old Bop It?
-The toy itself tells you
to bop it and then you bop it.
-Yeah.
And it was a hit.
-That's all I know.
-What you just described
was popular.
Of course it's not just Bop It.
You know you also, I think,
yank it, pull it, twist it,
twist it, flip it, and then
it gets faster and faster.
And right as you think
you finally
outsmarted the Bop It...
-Uh-huh.
-Game over.
Anyway, it didn't have
a very long shelf life,
but it was a big part
of our lives for probably
like three or four months.
Do you know this gentleman?
-Um, no.
A boxer?
-Mm-hmm. Do you think he's a
real boxer or a fictional boxer?
-I think he's fictional.
-Gotcha.
-Mm-hmm. And I think --
-Have you ever seen
any of the "Rocky" films?
-Oh! No!
But I know about Rocky.
[ Laughs ]
-Well, that's very unimpressive.
-He gets -- He gets knocked down
and then he gets back up.
-Yeah.
They wrote that song about him.
-"Tubthumping" by --
-Yeah, "Tubthumping"
was the "Rocky" theme song.
He would walk out
and they'd play "Tubthumping."
By the way,
I can't believe you
[bleep] pulled "Tubthumping."
[ Laughter ]
I would have thought 0% chance.
Do you know who sang
"Tubthumping"?
-Yes. Oh, my God, I do.
I know this because it was
an answer at, like,
a bar trivia thing
I went to a few months ago.
-Mm-hmm.
-Chumbawamba!
-Well, there you go.
Here we are trying to --
That was Ivan Drago.
Ivan Drago.
And he was a Russian.
And what do you think happened
in the fight when they fought?
-Wait, is this not Rocky?
-No, he fought Rocky.
-Oh, gotcha.
-Wait, you thought
that was Rocky?
-Yeah, sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-Again, I just can't --
Your brain both
has room for Chumbawamba
and not Sylvester Stallone.
-Oh, Sylvester Stallone, okay.
-Never -- We're going to move on
to the next one.
No chance.
Do you know who this is?
-Oh, no.
-It looks like Ivan Drago
going to a party.
[ Laughter ]
Probably shouldn't have put
those two next to each other.
Does Max Headroom
mean anything to you?
-No, yeah, sorry.
-That's Max Headroom.
He was basically presented to us
as sort of an A.I.-type fella.
He had a show, a very brief show
but then more importantly became
a sort of television pitchman
for New Coke.
-Like, the drink?
-Yeah.
-Oh. Fun.
-Did you hear about New Coke?
Did you hear about this?
-Is it -- By now is it just
what we call Coke?
-There was New Coke.
-Okay.
-Then they went back
to Coke Classic, right?
-Yes, that's where we are now.
-We had Coke Classic.
-Yeah.
-But we just call it Coke.
-Right.
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
Do you know who this is?
-Oh, no. I'm sorry.
But she looks so nice.
-You think she looks nice? Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Based on her look, what would
you guess she did for a living?
-Probably owned lots
of property?
-Okay, I think technically
there was some property issues
with what she was doing.
-Okay.
Was she like some sort of host,
presenter-type person?
-Yeah, she had
a television show.
Her and her husband
were presenters.
-Okay.
-And what do you think
they were talking about?
When you see a lady like that,
what do you think
she's telling you to do?
-To get your life in order.
-Yes.
There was some of that.
And if you were to follow
one person
to get your life in order...
-Oh, Jesus!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-My grandma will be so happy.
-Yeah, that was Tammy Faye
Bakker, and she was married
to a hot piece of garbage who's
closer to the devil than Jesus.
I think that's safe
to say, right?
-Sure.
-Yeah.
And, yeah, they were --
they had a television show.
Tammy Faye and Jim Bakker.
And Jim's still around,
and she is sadly --
rest in peace,
Tammy Faye Bakker.
I think she got
the raw end of the deal.
That's where I land on that one.
Here's our next one.
Who's this?
-Ooh, just a cool guy.
-He is a cool guy.
Cool is actually
half of his name.
-Is it Mr. Cool?
-No.
-Oh.
-But you're never going to get
it, so don't just keep guessing.
-Cool Red.
I'm going to keep guessing.
-Please, Karen, I'm telling you
you're not going to get it.
[ Laughter ]
-Cool Dude.
-Please, Karen, this is going
to go on forever.
-Cool Bug.
[ Laughter ]
-He was a pitchman as well,
also for soda.
What soda was this gentleman --
His name is Cool Spot.
-Mountain Dew.
-No.
But you're thinking
of the right color can,
but it's not Mountain Dew.
-Sprite?
-Again, same color,
but amazingly you're going
to guess the right one last.
-Wait, what? There's
Mountain Dew, there's Sprite.
There's another one
that's green and yellow?
Or green and red, sorry.
-1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6...
[ Laughter ]
-8, 8.
Wait, what did you just say?
-I said, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6...
-7-Up!
-There we go.
[ Laughter ]
He was the 7-Up Cool Spot.
And that was probably
my early teens,
and that's the kind of gentleman
I needed
to tell me what to be drinking.
-Nice.
-Again, it was him or that --
or Max Headroom.
I didn't have a lot of choices.
-Right. Cool Dude.
-Well, once again I feel like
we've accomplished not a ton,
but I think we've enjoyed
our time together.
-Yeah, this has been really fun.
Oh, but there's more.
-Oh, right.
-Yes.
-This is the part
I always forget about.
Now you, a person of
a different generation,
is going to see
if I know anything about your --
the things in your life.
-Yes.
These are things that were
important to me growing up.
-Okay, let's take a look.
-And just to be clear,
you've never seen
these pictures before.
-Alright.
-Do you know who she is?
-That looks like
a young Tammy Faye Bakker.
[ Laughter ]
On her way to school.
-Oh, my gosh.
-That's a children's book.
Is it a children's
book character?
-Mm-hmm.
-God, we're reading some kids
books now because of the boys,
but I don't think
we've read this one.
Is she a crime solver?
-Oh, actually kind of
in one of the books.
So, this is Kit Kittredge.
-Kit Kittredge. Okay.
-Mm-hmm.
She's an American Girl doll.
-Oh, she's
an American Girl doll.
-Yeah, yeah.
Well, this is the book
before the doll,
but she's great.
She lived during
the Great Depression,
and she was really into
writing and stuff.
-I'm glad she can be so upbeat
while the country starved.
[ Laughter ]
-It's something --
-Glad things are
going okay for Kit.
-[ Laughs ]
-Probably not a crossover
with "The Grapes of Wrath."
-[ Laughs ] I feel like --
-Alright.
Let's take a look at one more.
Oh, those are -- these are,
like, talking vegetables, right?
-Yeah! It's "VeggieTales."
-Is it some sort of pun off
vegetables or something?
-Yeah.
-The Veget-- the Vegetepeoples?
-No, but keep going.
-The Vegete-- the Vegete--
the Vegetebros?
[ Laughter ]
Vegete-- I don't know.
-It's called "VeggieTales."
-"VeggieTales."
-Yeah.
-It's great because they
tell you a lot of Bible stories.
-Do they really?
-Mm-hmm.
-So they're the real
Tammy Faye Bakker in all this.
-Yeah, they're very effective.
-They're effective?
-Yeah.
-Well, I guess in the end
that was probably the reason
we didn't go to church
that much in our family is
no vegetables
told us the upside.
[ Laughter ]
Karen, once again, I feel like
we're even closer
than we were before
because we've shared
our different
generational attractions.
Thank you so much for the time.
-Bye! Thank you!
-This has been
"What Does Karen Know?"
♪♪